all right i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report we are live streaming now
on rumble.com youtube and blaze tv and i
do realize that we are a few minutes
late today but when al gore the great al
gore
the magnificent al gore when he
developed the internet using a series of
tubes that he personally put together he
didn't do it exactly perfectly and we
had a little audio thing but i think we
worked it out and we got a great show
for you it is friday so it is round
table extravaganza time joining me our
author of the brand new book is atheism
dead eric mataxas
host of the aptly named podcast the liz
wheeler show liz wheeler and author of
another new book we've got a lot of
authors today
radical nation joe biden and kamala
harris's dangerous plan for america sean
spicer
you are all reuben report uh multiple
time guests welcome back everybody
thanks for having us
all right so uh
how gentlemanly of you by the way not to
blame the tech issues on me you are true
gentlemen
i don't know exactly what happened there
but i think it all worked itself out no
need no need to blame anybody all right
so there's a lot to get to this week uh
obviously you know this sort of odd
slow-motion revolution we're in
continues uh so we're going to hit on
all of that i want to start though i saw
this incredible thing on this
compilation of cnn headlines i saw this
i believe it was on originally the being
a libertarian instagram page conor can
we pull this image up this is just a
spectacular compilation of just sort of
the the nonsense that we have seen
endlessly i'm going to read these
headlines to you quick and this is in
chronological order all from cnn over
you know basically the last you know 10
months or so single pfizer vaccine shot
provides strong protection for those
who've had covet 19 uk studies suggest
people vaccinated against cloven 19 can
go without masks indoors and outdoors
cdc says cdc updates guidance recommends
vaccinated people wear masks indoors in
certain areas vaccine protection against
covet 19 wanes over time especially for
older people cdc says johnson and
johnson vaccine recipients should get
their second dose as soon as it's
possible uh experts say three days three
doses of covet-19 vaccine are likely
needed for full protection fauchi says
immunocompromise may need a fourth
coveted 19 shot cdc says why vaccinated
people dying from covet 19 doesn't mean
the vaccines are ineffective this is
just a small sampling of the crazy
conflicting
nonsense we have been spoon fed by
mainstream media
sean i will start with you on this one
as a man that worked for the previous
administration as a guy with the tv show
and someone that tries to communicate
some level of truth to people i'm
starting to think we can't trust cnn
what do you think well first i just got
to say i'm glad that we're doing this on
rumble because on youtube after
everything you just said
they would have shut this down you are
not that question lord fauci you know
better than that um look the level of
confusion and hypocrisy double standards
changing scenarios uh is
continues to be a problem and they
wonder why uh when they make these
mandates that people are confused and
and frankly don't trust the
government eric do you trust the
government or mainstream media more
which government
let's let's start with the united states
government how about that listen we you
want to talk about a teaching moment we
have been spoiled to death in america
we've had
really
generally trustworthy institutions you
cannot have
self-government
a republic unless you have
a people that trusts the institutions
generally speaking that has unraveled at
the speed of light uh in the last few
years but it's very healthy because it's
helping us as americans understand
that first of all we do have to think
for ourselves second of all uh we have
to know that when
corruption sets in when institutions
whether it's journalists whether it's
the the the medical universe
uh whether it's the government when they
begin giving you confusing information
you understand they're simply trying to
manipulate you they're saying let's
throw truth out the window
and let's use fear and pseudofacts to
manipulate people that leads to marxism
and we're in a moment in america most of
us never thought that we could get here
but we're seeing it with our own eyes if
they did it a little slower they might
get away with it but i think they have
woken up the sleeping giant that is we
the people so i find this actually an
exciting time not just a strange
horrifying time but an exciting and
hopeful time i like that answer because
that's what i'm always trying to say to
my audience the worse it gets it's like
they're throwing everything at us right
now and and people are waking up because
of it liz is that your sense that people
are finally i mean you can sort of tell
last couple days in virginia the polls
have changed because of critical race
theory and just yelling that junkins are
racist and everything do you sense that
the average person finally might be
waking up
yeah and i think it's it's because of
one thing and it's actually not because
the left is being so incredibly radical
they've been radical for quite some time
it's just because they're being so open
about it look there's there's a
difference between faith and trust
trust is earned and over the last year
and a half it's become very clear that
the government has not earned our trust
we don't owe it to them like a god we
don't owe them to have faith in their
actions or in their words or in their
policies or in anything that they're
doing they have to earn that and they've
betrayed us time and time again i mean
at the beginning of this pandemic we
were told locked down for two weeks to
stop the spread so that hospitals aren't
overwhelmed now what is it 20 months
later we are at get your fourth shot
still wear a mask and a new study in the
lancet says that you can still transmit
copit19 and you should give this vaccine
to your children even though the fda
says that they don't know whether it's
safe they're not going to know whether
it's safe until kids take it and we see
what kind of reaction they have
literally none of that none of that
should earn any of our trust whatsoever
and so it's it's prudent people it's not
just the left versus the right it is the
government versus the people right now
because they have betrayed us before and
they're restricting our rights doing it
yeah we covered it on my show yesterday
i mean this this idea that the 17-person
fda board that one of the guys was
caught on video his name is reuben no
relation i can't find one other decent
reuben out there at the moment uh but
this guy between jennifer rubin and this
guy but he literally said what what liz
just illustrated that we'll have to put
it we'll have to give it to the kids and
then we'll figure out what happens
that's how bananas this is
eric bring yep
you know
just like the stamp act forgive me oh
just i want to just say that this is
like 1765 the stamp act
uh
the the government of george iii
takes
one step too far
the american citizens uh colonists are
outraged and it leads to what we like to
call the american revolution what is
happening right now is just like that
it's a number of of overreaches that are
so astonishing that even your moderate
american says wait a second we didn't
sign up for this i'm out
sean go ahead
i was just going to say look look you
know we all have written books and when
you write a book the title is important
to convey what you wanted to
and i named the book radical nation for
a reason i didn't name it like kind of
radical or somewhat progressive because
to liz's point this idea that we're
gonna just tell people what to do and
kind of hope that it works but mandate
that they do it cancel out people who
don't agree with it get rid of first
responder i mean i just don't know
anything else to call it other than
radical the idea that we're spending two
trillion dollars and nobody's read a
bill and no one thinks that that's
insane i don't understand
you you look at afghanistan inflation um
the how we're dealing with covid every
single thing along this it's not just
one thing in isolation all of these
things are things that 10 15 years ago
if you had given me one of them and said
you're not going to believe what's going
to happen dave i was in a movie that i
filmed in 2019 called army of the dead
it came out just a little while ago it
was a science fiction movie about
making forcing people to take a vaccine
and and and the funny thing about it was
in august 2019 when zack schneider wrote
the movie that's how preposterous it was
the idea of forcing americans that they
had to take a vaccine or quarantine them
in a
isolated area of nevada which is what
the movie's all about
that's how crazy it is we went from
something that was supposed to be
someone's sci-fi movie to our reality
yeah and last point on this i just saw
right before we started uh that
california has decided that they're
going to keep kids in masks through all
of 2022 i mean that's how bananas this
is but but speaking about bananas liz
you helped break a story this week you
had an incredible twitter thread that
will will show as you're discussing what
happened but the u.s navy has basically
issued a blanket statement saying that
they are not going to have or allow for
any religious exemptions for the covid
uh vaccine can you explain what's going
on here
yeah it's super crazy and it's obviously
so disrespectful to our service members
who've sworn an oath to defend our
constitution and our nation our safety
and to treat those with religious
opposition to the kova 19 with such
animus is horrible but i've obtained
documents showing that at least at one
navy command of over 2 500 people and it
looks like it's also at other navy
commands um there's a plan behind the
scenes to issue blanket denials to
service members requests for religious
exemption to the coven 19 vaccine now
this is in violation of navy policy and
remember navy policy this isn't like a
private sector company having terrible
uh having terrible rules that they can
change at any point military policy is
the equivalent essentially to uh
military law so there's a military
policy that says when there's a
religious exemption to anything any
religious accommodation um but
especially as it relates to
immunizations that it has to be
evaluated on a case-by-case basis you
can't just issue blanket denials but the
documents that i've uncovered show that
um they do plan they actually have a
template that they're using to issue to
plan to issue these denials and the
template isn't a template that includes
oh here's you know the big picture and
you can choose either yes um accepted or
no denial no this template automatically
defaults to denial there's also this is
where it gets little military weeds
there's also a very specific chain of
command um that you use in the military
when you have when you request an
exemption or a religious accommodation
for a vaccine and it appears it appears
uh we certainly need to ask the question
whether this specific chain of command
is being violated by other people who
have an agenda to deny these vaccines
because we have evidence that there's
pretty significant animosity or
hostility towards people with religious
views of course the primary reason for
requesting an exemption to this vaccine
is in opposition to abortion and the
fact that aborted fetal cell lines were
used in the testing at least of the
pfizer and modern vaccines and the cells
themselves are included in the j j
vaccine and there's evidence of
hostility behind the scenes towards uh
pro-lifers in general in this viewpoint
in general so it certainly raises enough
questions that should be it should spark
a congressional inquiry because service
members are still allowed their
religious freedom in fact
the supreme court precedent here is that
religious accommodations in the military
should be granted when it's still
possible to accomplish the goal of the
military and if it's not possible to
accommodate them then it should only be
violated in the least restrictive means
manner and the burden is on the
government to show that and they are not
rising to that burden here yeah so this
is truly extraordinary stuff and i think
it gets to sean's point of like anything
that we believe 10 years ago you know
wouldn't be possible now is possible
eric i mean this is sort of in some ways
what your life's work has been about
you've written several books on religion
the newest book is atheism dead i mean
are we sort of at the place where where
uh an atheist secular society on
steroids has now decided to not only
really come for religious people but
anyone who won't bow to the orthodoxy
that's more important than the religious
part i think
that's the thing because of
uh the true christianity at the heart of
the founders vision
they said we have religious liberty in
america so anyone who wants to be an
atheist a muslim any kind of christian
anything you want we have to have
religious liberty in america if you
don't of course it leads to the
establishment of some kind of a religion
and what we're seeing now
uh is the establishment of a religion
with which is basically a kind of
practical atheism in other words we say
that look um we don't believe what we
used to believe we're not made in the
image of god uh we are we are
effectively marxists and we believe that
the government has the ability to do
whatever it likes uh because power is
power we used to believe that
person whether made in the image of god
or or not whether you believe that or
don't that we have an inherent sanctity
as individuals and our government
protected that so when i wrote my book
on dietrich bonhoeffer and you see how
quickly the nazis were able to destroy
a nation and take over a nation i
remember as i was writing it in the
years since thinking how is this going
to happen in america the way the jews
were demonized and marginalized how
would that happen in america
i didn't know how it would happen but
now i see it uh the vaccine idea that
was the idea that you can tell people
listen yes this was made
because of aborted fetuses uh but you
know what if it was made with the bodies
of jews we murdered in the concentration
camps who cares we're telling you you
need to get it whether you have an
objection to murdering jewish children
we don't care we're going to tell you
what to do the idea that that
dark logic
could have come to america the only good
news dave is that there are enough
americans willing to stand and fight
when you look at the example of what
happened in germany how the church was
sort of like not yet not yet not yet and
the moment they understood it was time
to fight it was too late i believe there
are still enough americans who
understand the basics of this understand
that all of these things are utter
outrages against america against the
idea of america and that we had better
stand and fight so these are all
examples of it it is happening very
quickly people are being demonized and
marginalized
by our quote unquote leadership i never
thought i'd see it but here we are yeah
well said and i like that phrase dark
logic i could see that being the title
of one of your upcoming books sean uh as
you know our president or the guy at
least pretending to be president joe
biden is in rome right now he's with the
pope he's uh a good catholic they always
tell me he's a devout catholic why would
a devout catholic president be attacking
religious liberty like this doesn't make
sense
you know it's funny that you bring that
up i have a chapter in my book that
walks through biden's evolution on
religious liberty and life it's funny
when he was a senator from delaware he
talked about the fact that he was
personally pro-life he didn't want to
see his views put on other people but he
was adamantly opposed about the federal
government funding abortion supporting
abortion he left it up to other people's
choices etc he was very vocal about his
catholic faith having a role in that uh
in that view and now he's gone full 180
he doesn't support the hyde amendment
the mexico city policy all these things
that prevented u.s tax dollars from
funding abortion has been thrown out the
window and he's suddenly become a an
abortion champion it's amazing the shift
that he has taken in order to win favor
with the far left of the democratic
party which frankly let's be honest he
had to do it if he had any hope of
winning a primary in the democratic
party that's where they are today but
it's fascinating i think that with
respect to the pope's visit though i do
i made this point earlier this week
the pope gave i think nancy pelosi a
pass
by not bringing this issue of life up if
he doesn't address it with biden today
and i i know that they have already met
but i don't know that we have a full
readout yet um it will be a huge not
just missed opportunity with biden but i
think we lose
we lose
authority as a church to go out and talk
about
why life is such an important issue if
you're not going to raise it with people
like biden and pelosi and i think it
will not just be a missed opportunity
but i think it'll be hard to to bring it
back up again
um when you with with people lower than
that if you don't bring it up with the
speaker of the house and the president
of the united states then then why how
can you tell any other regular citizen
that it's an issue yeah and by the way
you you briefly mentioned if i may jump
in yeah go ahead liz
if i might jump in here for just a
second joe biden says uh he claims that
after this this audience with the pope
that the pope told him that he can
continue to receive the eucharist
continue to receive communion now let me
just say i don't know if this story is
true joe biden is known to tell a
whopper or two but if this is true i
mean as a catholic i'm absolutely
disgusted there is almost no pinnacle
teaching as it relates to politics when
it comes to catholic catholic doctrine
that is clearer about the fact that
abortion is a grave moral evil and if as
a politician you participate in policy
that pushes abortion the way that biden
does then you are also in a state of
grave moral evil that means you are
immortal sin that means that you are
rejecting christ because the catholic
church teaches that all human beings are
made in the image of christ you cannot
simultaneously reject christ and receive
christ and if this pope my goodness
doesn't understand that and doesn't take
that up with the most powerful man in
the world or at least the man in the
most powerful position in the world then
i i mean this is so discouraging as a
practicing catholic i don't even know
what to say
this this pope
is doing for the catholic church what
joe biden is doing for america they are
both destroying the institutions
of which they are titular
pseudo heads
you know to shawn's point on mexico
which you mentioned really quickly we
fund abortions in mexico why the america
doesn't matter what your position on
abortion is uh why are we funding
abortions in other countries may want to
think about that a little bit but let's
move on to the second story here because
this was really an extraordinary thing
this week so everyone watching my show
gets the the fight against critical race
theory and of course the big story was
that merrick garland our attorney
general in essence was sicking the
department of justice on parents who
were showing up to school board meetings
to fight against it not because they
were actually doing anything truly
threatening but he was in essence
calling parents who show up and say hey
i want to be involved in my kids
education he was calling them domestic
terrorists well he had to testify this
week and it got a little spicy let's
take a look
you've cited
as the basis for that directive
the national school board association's
letter of september 29th was that
directive
being prepared before september 29th
before the school board association
letter was issued i don't believe so
certainly i didn't have any idea so it
was only prepared okay i think that
answers the question already answered so
you keep citing the school board letter
and news reports news right one of the
news reports signed in that letter which
you presumably mean is from loudoun
county virginia no that's not that is
not um what i was talking about well you
keep citing news reports and that's the
most prominent news report that anyone
in america has seen that refers to scott
smith whose 15 year old daughter was
raped
she was raped
in a bathroom by a boy wearing girls
clothes and the loudoun county school
board covered it up because it would
have interfered with their transgender
policy during pride month and that man
scott smith because he went to a school
board and tried to defend his daughter's
rights was condemned internationally do
you apologize to scott smith and his 15
year old daughter judge
senator anyone whose uh child was raped
as uh as a most horrific crime i can
imagine and is certainly entitled and
protected by the first amendment to
protest to their school board about that
but he was cited by the school board
association that's fine it's a domestic
terrorist which we now know that letter
and those reports were the basis for
your job
this is that's wrong judges is shameful
this here this testimony your directive
your performance is shameful okay that's
nice thank god you are not on the
supreme court
you should resign in disgrace judge
all right so i think uh actually we
somehow lost eric in the middle of that
we'll try to grab him back but that that
moment by tom cotton right there at the
end it's like we have so many
politicians who refuse to say anything
true and he just really dropped
something true there so just
sean go ahead go ahead i i felt like it
was reminiscent of the malt when mueller
was testifying how like ill-prepared he
was i mean i i don't know if garland's
staff
prepared him
like looked at a newspaper or did a
google search about key issues because
he looked flat-footed throughout the
entire process and i felt like
that as a someone who has staffed a lot
of principles in the past that it was a
real dis either he doesn't know what's
going on or his staff let him down or
both but
at the idea that he he seemed so
ill-prepared for this hearing and
understanding the source materials that
he had to have known were coming his way
really was to me the big takeaway yeah
so liz is this story
just like the perfect example of almost
everything in essence he got a one-page
letter that has since pretty much been
retracted saying that parents are
domestic terrorists he references that
letter and then he says media reports
are saying that parents are domestic
terrorists so we're going to do
something here at the the department of
justice and of course when i saw the
story breaking and i saw cnn picking it
up in msnbc picking up whatever else i
was like something doesn't add up here
like they've got one piece of paper next
thing you know the media is reporting on
it the fact that he even uses the media
as if that is evident of anything
doesn't it just tell you how just what a
perfect storm of nonsense this is
and by by the way too the woman who
crafted that letter from the school
board association the national school
board association and senate to uh
merrick garland she now has a position
in the biden administration on um on the
education governing board in the biden
administration this is after she wrote
that letter so the biden administration
is not even pretending that this is an
aberration or a mistake or an isolated
incident no no they're embracing this
this is why dave this is why yunkan is
up by eight points according to the
latest fox news poll in virginia because
it's no longer the left versus the right
this is the left versus parents
everywhere you don't have to be a
republican a republican or a
conservative or anything close to
understand that your daughter is at risk
if men are allowed in in the bathroom
with her that your child is at risk if
they're going to be indoctrinated with
ideology that teaches them that they're
racist if they have white skin and
oppressed if they have black skin this
is no longer a partisan fight this is
parents versus the left and the left
instead of doing what they normally do
and pretending that they don't embrace
this radical view they are actually
doubling down and it's causing parents
to be like well then you don't represent
me and we're going to vote for your
opponent as they should right so this is
sort of eric's point from earlier sean
do you think we kind of owe them a
thanks in a way when they've gone so far
where they will tell you that we're
going to inject your kids with stuff and
by the way we don't know what's going to
happen until we do it and then we'll
figure it out or we say we're going to
call you all domestic terrorists for not
wanting this neo-racism in school it's
like it's one thing to attack the adults
but now that they've shifted it to the
kids maybe we do owe them a thanks here
because the great awakening might be
upon us
yeah i agree i think that's absolutely
right you think about how many people
are now engaged in the political process
that weren't otherwise that are
attending school board hearings that are
running for the school board but then
the worst part is that you have barack
obama coming into virginia talking about
it being a made-up controversy a
right-wing thing i mean the bottom line
is i literally have a chapter in my book
radical nation documenting its origins
what it seeks to achieve this is not
made up this is very real and in school
district after school district parents
are having these conversations i talked
to one parent about a month and a half
ago who's telling me that they have to
write essays as parents talking about
how in the home they are addressing
their white privilege with their kids
and it's like that the parents and if
they don't do it and then i talk about
one other example where there's a woman
uh who's actually asian she came out
against some of the things that were
going on in the school and the group of
parents that were supporting this called
her employer called the hr department
and said we just wanted to alert you to
some of her racist behavior outside of
the workplace in case anything comes up
inside the workplace you know that it's
a pattern but these are the tactics that
they are employing to get their way and
to cancel and shout down everybody
man our work is cut out for us but i
would love if i if a teacher ever asked
me to write a letter like that i would
be absolutely happy to send one back to
the school tongue and exactly what i
think of white privilege
well liz you sent out a tweet last night
basically saying they are never going to
inject my kids with this stuff simple as
that
absolutely not no question i mean you
honestly i i don't mean to be rude here
i don't know a nicer more diplomatic way
to say it but if as a parent you give
this vaccine to your five to 11 year old
when they admit the fda admits that they
don't know what kind of risks or
long-term effects or short-term effects
whether it's even safe at the same time
that we know that your child of that age
is more likely to die if they contract
the flu than if they contract covet 19
then you're a bad parent
yeah it really is as simple as that all
right let's get to the third story we're
trying to get eric back here but i hold
you i think you guys can hold hold your
own uh if in case we don't uh so biden's
got this build back better thing we all
know they tried to pass this thing 3.5
trillion dollars equals zero math
doesn't matter anymore it has almost
nothing to do with infrastructure but
now everything's infrastructure we've
got some info here from the daily wire
president joe biden debuted an updated
version of his build back better
spending plan this time scaled back from
the 3.5 trillion human infrastructure
plan proposed months ago in hopes that a
fractured democratic party can unite
behind both this and the bipartisan
physical infrastructure bill uh the
language they reintrodu the reintroduced
bill comes on the heels of a string of
white house failures in selling a more
ambitious build-back better spending
bill which would have spent double the
new 1.7 trillion compromise package
progressives were not willing to back a
bipartisan infrastructure bill without a
guarantee that ex the expansive spending
measure would pass the senate and key
senators were not willing to back the
expansive spending bill without major
cuts i mean of course the hilarity here
really is that if 3.5 trillion dollars
actually equals zero then what does
1.75 trillion equal and what is it that
we can't get done at that point sean you
have a little insight in how the
messaging comes out of it administration
how did they do here
i think buildback better is now scaled
back worse i mean that that should just
it's you still have close to two
trillion dollars that comes on the heels
of three trillion that we spent earlier
this year i mean i just read this
morning that they can't account this is
from propublica a left-leaning
organization they don't they can't
account for the money they sent to
schools we know that the money set aside
for rental and mortgage assistance 40
billion of 49 billion hasn't been used
or discovered this is they are literally
creating a price tag and then working
backwards figuring out how much you
spent the idea that two trillion
dollars trillion trillion trillion is
scaling things back
i don't this is what world are we living
in where this is happening but dave here
is my
strategy for every republican i said it
on the show last night to congresswoman
kat kamik and i'll say it out here now
every republican needs to just say the
following we are in the minority we have
no say in this you will pass whatever
bill you want so here's what i would ask
of you speaker pelosi let your own
members read it
give them enough time because that's my
challenge name one member of congress
that can actually say
at the time that they vote for it that
they actually have read it there is no
physical way that they will have done
that
liz is that it that this is just all
just like a nonsensical shell game not
that whether it's 3.5 trillion or 1.5
that's almost irrelevant nobody's read
it that's almost irrelevant they are
just doing anything under the guise of
we're trying to help you because we've
wrecked everything well they don't tell
you that we've wrecked everything but
that's really what's going on here
they're wrecking everything so in
essence they can just get more of our
money it's as simple as that
yeah i mean i never thought i'd say this
before and i'll probably never say this
again but i really appreciate
congresswoman alexandria ocasio-cortez
and congresswoman ilhan omar and all of
these progressives derailing this
because the longer we can prevent this
from being imposed on the american
people the better for us all i mean
they're using they're using this
strategy that dave you and i and several
other conservative commentators
identified a long time ago where they
take the idea of an emergency and they
use this idea of emergency to instill
fear in people and then when people are
crippled with fear and hysteria they say
we'll be your saviors we'll rescue you
if only you let us have control and a
lot of people in their fear in this
facing what they think is an emergency
they hand over their rights and their
freedoms and their and even some
privileges and control and power and the
government under joe biden and his
radical administration sean is exactly
right to name his book radical nation
under this radical administration they
are not going to stop trying to take our
rights and our liberties and power and
freedom until we say enough and stop
letting them do it and this this bill is
just another example i mean it's rife
with their agenda climate change and
abortion and taxes on the rich and
crippling the economy and all kinds of
stuff that hurt everyday americans that
will cause the price of goods to go up
and our wages to go down cause jobs to
be scarcer cause all kinds of
ramifications that the liberal elite in
washington dc won't feel but you and i
will look i want to say one quick thing
that everyone needs to understand is
crucial and this is the point that i
make in the book whether it's the
spending making dc state passing or
packing the court letting
folks flow over illegally our southern
border federalizing elections every
single thing is in pursuit of permanent
political power it all ties together
it's not about a policy it's about how
much money can we get out of the
government to people to get them
addicted it's allowed voting rights it's
not it's it's about creating people who
will keep them in power it's about
creating a state that will give them two
democratic senators everything that the
left is doing right now is in pursuit of
permanent political power and that is
crucial to understanding everything that
they do in their motives
yeah well said sean on that note on that
note guys wait well uh we do have to
wrap unfortunately but sean you are in
la right now at a hotel i will not
reveal your location so that your fans
don't mob the hotel but you normally you
live in florida is that correct
no i live in virginia you live in
virginia i thought you were in florida i
was gonna have a really nice florida
ending to this thing because i'm gonna
see liz over the next couple days at the
national conservatism conference i'm
leaving tomorrow morning i'll be in
florida
for a week i thought maybe we could have
figured out some sort of florida
i'm going down i'll be down in a week
down so so i i might i mean who knows
i'll be down there from the 4th of
november to uh the 9th i think oh all
right well i'll still be there for at
least part of that uh guys i'm going to
finish up without you but i appreciate
you picking up the heavy lift we lost
eric i don't know what happened maybe
they maybe they got him you know they
got it
that's what i was told the agent
he said go buy your book
the agents got youtube at the beginning
so you never know oh well there you go
thank god we're on rumble all right guys
have a great weekend i'm going to finish
up without you and liz i'll i'll see you
tomorrow
all right everybody
all right a little uh a little technical
snafu today uh we had a little something
up front and then we lost eric somehow
the pipes what can i tell you the pipes
they're weird on this internet which is
why we are going to build a parallel
internet and that's why this week was
was so huge uh not only for me
personally but i really really think
this week
is going to be remembered for a long
long time because i think the rumble
acquisition of locals is just such a
perfect
melding of companies that are trying to
fight the big tech nonsense
um growth on both sides were was
spectacular this week i'm really proud
of what we've done
i want to give a shout out by the way to
my co-founder of locals asaph who not
only sold his first company this week
but became an american citizen
this morning this very morning so south
i'm going to see you tomorrow and uh
dinner is on me welcome to america my
friend uh like what a great american
story that is like you sell a company
and become a citizen the same week like
the american dream is still alive and
some of us just need to wake up to find
it right uh on that note i am heading to
florida tomorrow if you guys are in the
florida area or if you can get there i
am speaking uh at the national
conservatism conference marco rubio josh
hawley peter teal
uh liz wheeler chris ruffo michael
knowles give me a couple other names who
else do we got there everybody uh glenn
lowery it uh ted cruz like it's just
sort of everybody that i think is sort
of interesting politically right now and
the people that are trying
to figure out once we get through this
progressive madness what will america
look like and guess what it's going to
look pretty broad politically and i
think that can all fit under
this sort of new conservatism umbrella i
really do i'll probably be a little more
on the libertarian side of it there'll
be a little more of a religious side of
it like it can work and we're gonna
really that's what the whole purpose of
the conference is it's a four day
conference to really churn through how
do we take all of the things that we
love about america but then accept that
we can't necessarily have everything we
want and there's going to be all sorts
of people living here and we don't want
to jail them even if they want to jail
us that's what the whole conference is
going to be douglas murray will be there
i'm giving a couple talks i'm opening
the conference tomorrow uh no not
tomorrow i'm opening the conference on
uh sunday and then i have a solo talk
i'm doing something with douglas and
jerome harzoni and sora bamari so it's
just going to be a great conference if
you can get to orlando
please do join us we'll be taping some
shows there locals is sponsoring the
event and then i'm spending a couple
extra days in florida i have my reasons
okay
i've said enough have a good weekend
everybody and we'll see you on monday